the fastest lap the most efficient
powertrain the best overall design that
is what Formula Student is all about but
this is not a normal race it is more a
context of ideas offered by 115 teams
from universities in 24 countries young
people have the opportunity to design
their own we can wander around and look
at everything and the atmosphere is
really friendly there's maybe a
competition that the teams are happy to
help each other no professor on earth
teaches everything we're learning here
by bringing car makers including
Volkswagen support the events at the
Hockenheimring
racetrack this is where we find the
engineers of tomorrow we have to be
involved in be visible as an interest is
partner and as a potential future
employer and for those to come to your
Albert Gilliland off with on boats is
like 65 cars have internal combustion
engines 50 electric motors the teams had
one year to build their racing cars and
galvanize their fans to cheer on their
pilots there are parallels to the real
auto industry
[Music]
this is not a completely new development
after our failure last year we met with
some alumni of experts and looked at
what went well and what didn't on the
basis of that we modified our car 15
teams came without a driver not because
they couldn't climb one they didn't need
one
they developed self-driving racing cars
for the driverless discipline
then to register the driver is always
the biggest problem in a car so our aim
was to replace the driver with systems
that do his job the problem is a system
to do everything the driver does in
every respect a system that you see and
react and act spontaneously even
professional racing drivers are
astounded by what the students have
developed in such a short time and with
limited resources
this will be the technology of tomorrow
it's so cool how many young people are
interested in this and have gotten
involved in five or ten years times this
is what will probably be driving around
it it's just great what these youngsters
have come up with Sandia Midcoast ID to
finish guns goes on the jury looks at a
range of parameters including
aerodynamics acceleration handling
design technology and costing
performances important of so is
reliability
[Music]
the jurors already have an idea about
weak teams often have it's the same
kinds of problems
so the jurors like to focus on the sore
points I think they evaluate all the
teams the same way every team would like
to win but that's really not the main
issue for most of them at this special
meet
[Music]
manly and you just learned so much is
it's amazing also in terms of social
skills
that's something I've realized is team
leader learning how to get on with
people work with them and coordinate
their activities that is it's incredibly
valuable the interaction is really
impressive we all talk to each other all
the teams come up with different ideas
and you can learn a lot from them no
design so far is being perfect who knows
perhaps two teams with two approaches
working together could make something
really good that would mean progress not
just for Formula Student but also for
the auto industry and for the future of
Transportation no matter that not
everything works perfectly right now